let's close out year-in-review by doing
this a list of things in 2019 I hate my
favorite list of every year all right
this is the list we've compiled a list
of everything that I hated in 2019 and
when I hear this back I go man I'm
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] a movie theaters I
hate the way I look
I hate Michael Jackson I [ __ ] hate
vinyl I [ __ ] hate people collect
vinyl I hate horse-racing
I got up early this morning I hate that
I [ __ ] hate people and I hate the
Internet I [ __ ] hate top 40 I hate
the city and a gym teachers I hate
driving with a passion I hate swimming
I [ __ ] hate rattlesnakes I [ __ ]
hate women who go to his store they buy
a dress they wear it somewhere and then
they return it I [ __ ] hate Russia oh
my god the what there's nothing more I
hate on the planet than packing I hate
hotels
I hate fireworks I hate Halloween with
such a passion I hate parties
I hate daylight savings time I wish
there was just one time period I hate
that I hate this [ __ ] planet and the
people on it Wow Wow a lot of anger I
can't wait till next year we're sitting
here and it starts off with I hate
puzzles yeah that's right that's the
first entry for 2020